Choosing the right algorithm and choosing an appropriate floating-point format
are just 2 of the issues we encounter when we implement a solver,
a program to solve a differential equation.
On a higher level, one may think about reusability and maintainability.
This is my replica rendering of the Plug and Play style
of implementation that's used in the book "Numerical Recipes."
With this type of implementation, you can mix and match components,
which comes in very handy for experiments.
Let's have a closer look: 1 minor but vital component
is the right hand side; the right hand side of the differential equation, that is.
The rate of change. It's used by the algorithm,
the algorithm being, for instance, the forward Euler method, Hunt's method, and similar.
The algorithm is called by the stepper.
which controls which steps are being made at which size.
The stepper is responsible to adapt the step sizes
and maybe to reduce the steps when it finds the error has grown too large.
So the algorithm is only able to do 1 single step.
The stepper calls the algorithm.
The driver is the interface to the user,
which, of course, is a program and not a human.
The driver can be sent commands to start and stop,
and eventually the driver returns the data to the user.
To this end, it has a subobject that's called output.
The output may collect values at predefined instances of time,
or it may interpolate the data it receives from the stepper to regular time intervals.
The stepper will pick smaller and larger time intervals.
The output may interpolate them to produce data at regular time intervals.